so this is one of the most common
questions I'm getting which is people
still don't know what work is going to
look like in the future and by the way
nobody knows and anybody who's making
any Grand prediction of what it's going
to be like they don't know either the
only thing that we do know that I think
I can confidently say is here to stay is
flexibility is here to stay for example
we used to have to ask permission to
work from home next Thursday because my
kid's going to be home now we can simply
send an email in the morning going hey
I'm working from home today you know and
everybody will be fine with it we got
used to that but in terms of what hybrid
work looks like or how we get people to
come back to work if they don't want to
come back that is still a big unknown
the dust is still in the sky I think
unfortunately for employers 2023 is
still going to have a little bit of
uncertainty I think we're going to just
have to Fumble through it for probably
another year